eu vim para trazer o carro bom dia
pois é bom é pra quem não me conhece eu
sou não só um editor de vídeo
mas eu sou um produtor de conteúdo para
internet
a gente trabalha não só com um jovem
nerd mas que é fizemos trabalho proposta
de fundos e para a globo e eu queria
citar este exemplo da globo a globo
chegou até nós nem a minha a minha
empresa gaveta filme e falou olha a
gente tem o nosso material aqui é um
programa feito pra pra televisão ea
gente quer colocar na internet mas senti
que aquela pegada na internet sabe que
você tem o seu quê ela então aí veio
aquela pergunta existe uma linguagem
típica para internet né eu vou falar
quem especificamente no youtube está
porque o youtube ele é a minha praia e
tudo mais é claro tem vídeos dele
facebook tudo mais mas vão 18 por si só
já é uma mídia é uma rede social que tem
o seu próprio comportamento então é como
é que a gente faz pra pensar um conteúdo
destinado para ela é existe diferença
existe eu vou citá
tem alguns fatores né tem um fator da
mídia tem um fator social também deixa
eu falar primeiro é da comparação entre
as mídias vão se sair cinema tv e
internet
é o cinema é uma caixa preta parecendo
pessoal história aqui você senta focado
nessa sala escura som alto
você tá vendo aquela imagem totalmente
pra você você não tem interferência
externa nenhuma você desliga o telefone
e ninguém pode falar nada
então você pode se dar o luxo de você
ver uma cena e ela ter um tempo para
falar lento e você aceita isso que você
está ali no no cinema você tá vendo
aquele que não se importa que o cara tá
o ator tá falando dessa forma lenta
nisso na internet talvez não funcione
mas no cinema você tá aí tudo bem
já na televisão
né já o tempo está mais rápido né você
tá vamos pegar o o padrão que a
televisão no centro da casa por mais que
você chega em casa vou ver televisão
você tem a probabilidade de você ser
interrompido é muito maior então a
televisão ela sabe disso então o ritmo
dela de edição é mais rápido ela começa
a colocar coisas mais rápidas é é os
problemas tendem a ser menores um pouco
mais curtos
eu vou citar um exemplo aqui todo mundo
conhece ou friends que é uma série feita
para a televisão e para quem conhece a
história do frente sabe que eles têm um
tempo mínimo no roteiro para colocar
piadas não pode ficar muito tempo sem
piada de tanto tempo tem que ter uma
guerra uma pena porque o cara está
preocupado empreender sua atenção e ele
tem concorrente ele alguém você pode
sair para comer uma e você pode trocar o
canal
então ele tem que se ter certeza que
você está assistindo ao contrário do
cinema que você tá ali você vai ver o
filme até o final é e então tem já um
ritmo muito mais rápido e ainda a
internet é loucura internet é muito mais
rápido e se como tô falando do início da
linguagem 10 de outubro eu tô falando
início além da internet que a
publicidade a gente não tinha é produção
feita especificamente para o youtube
então o computador basicamente é aquele
vídeos em que você vê no meio do
trabalho só que você não chega em casa
pega um pacote que pode envolver
internet e aí você fica rodando o
outlook isso ela não você não é que você
tem é um time rápido você vê no meio do
caminho então por exemplo um vídeo de
internet hoje em dia um vídeo de 20
minutos não é todo mundo que vive de 20
minutos é a gente até produz o jovem
nerd desse tamanho em castanhal também
faz isso mas é não é comum nem você não
vê o tempo inteiro à u
só vejo vídeos gigante da internet é um
vídeo 20 minutos ele é considerado
grande pela internet para a televisão é
meio programa né
dependendo nenhum programa é parte de um
programa 20 minutos é tranqüilo com a
televisão o cinema é o trailer passou 20
minutos de treino já passou
então tem esse problema de duração na
internet ela precisa segurar sua atenção
muito rápido
é isso
impacta também na produção eu vou citar
aqui sempre o meu lado da produção eu
como editor e tem uma técnica que ela se
popularizou na internet
james dean picante você tem as falas das
pessoas e você vai tirando o respiro
entre a fala da pessoa eu quero falar no
assunto a 1 e agora só fala no assunto
de depois da inflação o bc é muito comum
na internet você vê
eu tô falando às 14 falar no assunto
beijo alterações e teve a pessoa mudar
de lugar
também tem a ver com a informalidade da
internet na televisão não pode ter as
pessoas mudando de lugar está
transportando mas na internet acho que a
gente tem esse problema né
e tem um outro fator que é já um fator
social vamos dizer assim é uma fase
muito batida mas a internet ela é
democrática
então a internet ela possibilitou um
cara não você não precisa mais ser um
ator que está no na televisão e tudo
mais um apresentador
você pode ser um cara que mora no rio de
janeiro no interior de minas no panamá
no interior do piauí em simandou nderson
importa você pode produzir conteúdo para
a internet
eu quero fazer o meu canal de álbum de
figurinhas de futebol pratica essa razão
então você vai lá e vai começar a fazer
o seu canal
é o que acontece é o seguinte a maioria
das pessoas começa a fazer direto o
vídeo ea maioria das pessoas também não
tem informação com um ator como o
apresentador normalmente um ator
apresentador ele tem técnicas pra
segurar um público né
e vai falando ele tem gancho se alguma
coisa de ruim ele puxa o cara que tá em
casa na liga a câmera começa a falar
então obviamente por uma questão de
necessidade e vivendo o material dele
eles começaram a me ligar viu a 1 não dá
para depender da atuação entre vai
depender de um outro fator que é a
edição a produção estou aqui
representando esse lado bonito da esfera
né ele começa a depender mais da
pós-produção então o vídeo para internet
ele depende muito mais disso né primeiro
nesse elenco foi agora do fluxo de
atacante ele usa isso a favor dele então
ele começa na edição a montar a atuação
dele ele falou nessa parte que também o
chato tira essa parte bota aqui
bota
e já faz o corte vir a própria piada eu
faço isso muito menos vídeos também é e
aí você
aos poucos a partir da necessidade você
está começando a criar uma estética né
outra coisa que é muito comum de
internet você usar em sétimo é você
pegar um em chama de inserções que é
você pegar um videozinho e botar pra
representar alguém fala alguma coisa dê
uma resposta torta de um coice de um
cavalo alguma coisa desse tipo
é esse tipo de coisa é uma necessidade
de expressão
normalmente um ator de comédia se virar
sozinho na internet começou por uma
necessidade e agora é uma estética né e
aí as pessoas começaram a fazer só que
eu tinha um problema eu vinha é eu vou
começar a fazer esses vídeos não vou
começar a fazer esse tipo de coisa eu
tenho que delegar isso pra minha empresa
eu venho de uma empresa chamada fly que
era uma empresa de efeitos visuais
normalize empresa de efeitos visuais do
brasil ea gente tinha
é a gente fazer comerciais de tv de 30
segundos e 60 segundos comercial de tv e
eu tinha mais ou menos um mês para fazer
isso aí né há dois meses para fazer um
comercial de um minuto
e aí eu comecei a minha empresa fazendo
um vídeo do jovem nerd e que tinha que
fazer 40 minutos e não 30 segundos em
uma semana na cidade - uma semana
então foi um exercício de desapego
enorme
a primeira coisa que eu digo fazer foi
na verdade um sócio para organizá-la
chão só se ele falou cara você tem que
delegar daí você tem que desconstruir o
seu método para que você possa delegar
passar por que cortar vídeo todo mundo
sabe o importante é a pessoa aprender a
aas técnica a linguagem é como como
passar é exatamente o que a globo estava
procurando como procura a gente então eu
comecei a observar algumas coisas
é eu vou criar uma vovó pegar uma cena e
eu vou ter que criar uma piada pra ela
tá é eu vou criar uma cena que vamos
supor que é um campo verde e val tá e aí
você tem um guerreiro que é o herói
nelma claudia está com as palavras de
será que eu gosto de misturar as coisas
tantas para a justiceira está vindo que
estão vindo cavaleiros cavaleiros do
mapa
destruir a cloud estão vindo estudo está
filmado estudo foi realizado então tá
tudo bem
nesse tempo que uma causa está aqui
assim vem uma gripe e tiras para nele
temos uma situação de humor pra
acontecer né então que acontece aí que o
lance da edição ela está muito mais
presente a pós produção está muito mais
presente é eu gosto de fazer humor
eu gosto de ver acho que o humor sempre
brinca com o inesperado eu gosto de
brincar com o inesperado né
mas não é um alerta o inesperado
aleatório você vai entregar o que a
pessoa quer que a pessoa espera mas não
do jeito que ela espera
então por exemplo no momento em que
ficou sem espaço ele vai ter que fugir
meu deus do céu em câmera lenta vai
virar uma cena em câmera lenta e pescar
tem que ter uma música dramática eu vou
botar uma música dramática da maria
bethânia porque eu sou desde então a
graça é você brincar com esse contraste
entender então o cara começa a música em
câmera lenta vem o cara mata lauquen
chamou que vai querer voltar nem aí a
brincadeira está nisso então o que
acontece eu tenho fazer essa piada
acontecer
a primeira coisa que eu tenho que fazer
é o roteiro é outra coisa que é muito
específica da linguagem de internet e
tem muito a ver com a minha empresa é a
gente tem um roteiro de edição
normalmente uma produção de tv ela tem
um roteiro de tv
então faça o ator tem que chegar vai ter
que correr acabou e depois só bota pega
o material filmado bota produtor um
editor faz a gente não
depois que filma pedra faz uma predição
a gente em que faz um novo roteiro que a
gente vai fazer aqui uma cena que
maneira vão votar maria betânia e tudo
mais então aí eu consegui desconstruir o
que eu faço assim olha o que é o mais
importante
antigamente quando da silva eu queria
fazer uma letrinha bota letra adaptada
da música na tela eu pedi um tempo hoje
em dia eu sei que o mais importante é o
time mais importante a piada está no
time dela né o windows phone sheik o
diga o antes dele o time dele é o corte
tudo mais
então eu vou estar preocupado cá tudo
nessa cena está sincronizado com a
música né neta você verá que mesmo assim
história não tem fim e mostra morrendo e
vou fazer todo 5 dessa maluquice pronto
tem a piada a mas sobrou ainda eu tinha
quatro horas para fazer essa parte aqui
e na verdade eu fiz aqui em duas então
agora vou colocar a letra na tela e isso
dá um tempo ainda então vamos botar uma
bolinha de karaokê com essa inventava
água passando o importante é você
desconstrói ea gente vai construindo
esse é o que essa essa linguagem é
típica típica da internet que é de você
complementar
você por exemplo eu já vi
já teve gente que foi pro teve o tube
que foi papa vai pra te ver né ou então
vai pra um programa de entrevistas e aí
teve um senhor que fala pra mim é esse
cara não leva jeito olha só ele não sabe
falar com o público e talento ele não
sabe falar porque está fora da mídia
dele tá ele está na televisão a
televisão tem um ritmo diferente né até
ele sabe contar a história dele dentro
do meio dele que a internet tá é então
um importante agente adaptar nossa
história o nosso meio
eu até falei pro senhor fala olha ele
não sabe e não está sabendo porque ele
não ele está fora do domínio da mídia
dele mas eu tenho certeza que o seu
filho assim ele com certeza bastante
então o importante é você contar sua
história do seu jeito não importa as
artimanhas eu sei a técnica de à tona
num importante a história importante
você cativar o público tá seja qual for
o método que você utilizar é a internet
está contando a história do jeito dela
eu estou contando a história do meu
jeito e eu acho que essa história ainda
tem muito a evoluir néné pichette está
vindo aí é é já veio na verdade né que
um novo método de contar histórias sem
edição promete vai ter alguma outra
inovação tecnológica então o que eu
posso fazer é ficar antenado
e sempre está prestando atenção de
adaptar a história ao meio né adaptar o
az técnica ao público que vai receber
essa história e é isso com cuidado
[Aplausos]